i won't have anybody with me i think the
thing that i'm most scared of is like
losing my marbles
[Music]
good morning happy tuesday i want to
show you this cute little plant that i
got this weekend
take a look
it's so cute but if you can see this
little bulby thing this part gets bigger
and it starts looking like a tortoise
shell
and i just loved the cute little like
green heart thing but yeah a lot of
things going on in my life recently i
am thinking about going to japan in
march mid-march till early april it's
been like in the plans for a while but
it's just you know with covet i was like
i don't know if it's gonna be realistic
so i just kind of put off thinking about
it and deciding until the last minute
and now that time is here we're like a
month away and i'm kind of like i should
probably make moves now it's been
consuming my reign because i'm so scared
the thing that i'm scared about mostly
is the flight scott can't come with me
because he's not a citizen or a
permanent resident so he's not allowed
into the country this is my first time
going to japan by myself i'm usually on
a flight with scott or my dad or my
brother or my mom like i've always flown
with somebody else i mean i i've
developed a lot of flight anxiety uh
like in the last five years like
turbulence really freaks me out the
anticipation of taking off really freaks
me out and usually like you know i lean
on mostly scott to kind of help me get
through that and like my family and
stuff i feel like i'm crying thinking
about it because i'm just like so scared
of it the thing with flying alone is
that i won't have anybody with me
to work through that
and i think the thing that i'm most
scared of is like losing my marbles and
like having a panic attack without
anybody there to
kind of soothe me
[Music]
i think i just have to be in a really
good mental place in order to be able to
go and be okay
but i do have therapy later which is
helpful because i think i'm gonna talk
through this and work through this and
just right now the fear is like
all-consuming and there are moments
where i'm just like oh it'll be so
exciting because i have to see my mom my
dad and it'll be so exciting cause i've
been in japan since pre-pandemic it'll
be so exciting because i have certain
meetings set up with people i've been
working with in japan it'll be so fun
but
right now all i can think about is the
scary part hello still
tuesday was 6 30 p.m i
just worked out for the first time in
like three months
felt great so i just took a shower and
i'm gonna do some work
because the work don't stop and it don't
stop coming y'all i have a book deadline
for the end of march once it's out i'll
post it in the
gyorang description box all the places
obviously i'll make announcements for
all of it yeah i'm writing a japanese
book if you didn't know i had therapy
earlier today it was very helpful back
on the train of i don't think i'm gonna
go to japan
my therapist was like it seems like
going to japan would be a really big
jump for you she never tells me to do
things or not to do things but it was
helpful to be like yeah maybe i am
stretching myself a little bit too much
here i flip-flop every single day so i'm
gonna wait for a couple more days before
i make a final decision because
otherwise i'm giving everyone that i'm
telling about this whiplash i did a lot
of crying today but i feel better now
working out meditating spending time
with scott now writing here's my view
for today
i'm just gonna write for
an hour or so and then i'm gonna eat
dinner
cause your girl needs rest
so let's do this thing
hello happy
wednesday everybody i got such good
sleep last night i
been very tired and last night i finally
got some really restful sleep and today
just feels lighter it's like one of
those lessons that i keep just learning
over and over again as an adult if you
sleep well your day is better i remember
when i first learned in college that if
i just got enough sleep every night life
would be infinitely easier and more
beautiful
yeah now it's the afternoon it's 1 15. i
gotta get started on work but i've been
really craving something sweet and
who better than to help satiate this
need then sakurako who is the sponsor of
today's video so for those of you who
are not familiar with sakuraku yet it is
a monthly subscription box that sends
you japanese sweet snacks treats and tea
pairings to your door every month inside
there's a bunch of traditional artisanal
and authentic japanese snacks and i like
can't find these at even regular asian
markets in the us oh also i should also
mention that every box comes with like
one japanese wear too which is really
nice each box comes with a really cute
little postcard as well as a booklet
that includes all the information about
this month's theme as well as the snacks
and where they're from
and what allergens are there and some
japanese cultural tips too it's hanami
season so that's like the whole practice
of japanese people going outdoors having
a picnic under the beautiful sakura
blossom trees so the theme for this box
is that you can do that at home there's
a lot of good stuff in here sakura bama
kuhn like a little cake thing sakura
bread
it's like munju
look at the wear for this one that's
beautiful i think i'm actually going to
try one of these
which looks really good manju is
basically like a japanese confectionary
sort of thing it looks like this
cute cute
oh damn
that tastes like japan i'm also going to
try this matcha cookie
sweet green tea cookie as well oh
look at how green that is
it tastes like green tea but a very like
kind green tea
like flavor that's really good too so if
you'd like the march box then make sure
to sign up by february 28th and use this
code to get five dollars off your first
sakotako order or through the link in
the description box thank you as always
to sakuraku for sponsoring and providing
all these really really yummy cheats
excited to do some afternoon tea and get
some work done this afternoon
happy
friday
we just got our csa box
our what is it called something
something agriculture dang there's a lot
of things in here wow
what oh it has green onions look at all
these gorgeous vegetables apples
tomatoes oranges or even an artichoke i
don't think i've ever cooked artichoke
before you said that last time you made
artichoke we've been wanting to eat more
healthy farmers markets like we don't
have any that are super close to us
they're like 15 20 minutes away just
because we're in an awkward spot so we
were like we want like local
vegetables and fruits but how can we get
it and then we realized csa boxes are a
thing this one actually is called
yasukochi farms they're based in
oceanside san diego and they deliver all
throughout did you just eat them
um
that's pretty good
they deliver off to san diego not
sponsored it's funny because i went to a
i went to high school with someone with
that same last name so i think it's his
family
but i mean
is like a japanese name so it's like a
japanese-owned business which is cool of
course it's asian owned because it comes
with shiitake mushrooms and green onions
[Music]
i still went to trader joe's yesterday
for me though and look i bought these
daffodils
they're so cute i've never had daffodils
in my home before i'm gonna make lunch i
think i'm gonna make fried rice because
i saw it on tv yesterday and maybe crave
it and i'm gonna use all the vegetables
that we just got carrot tomati what is
this onion green onions chinese sausage
and the eggs my sister-in-law got us
the
our place pan so i've been using it
every day for like the last three days
pretty good so far so i'm still kind of
figuring out
how to use it best this is gonna be
hardly anything
but authentic i think it's probably like
a mix of
japanese style cha hung japanese tail
fried rice which is inspired by chinese
fried rice it's kind of like american
italian food where it's not really
authentic but it's authentic
it has roots in authenticity
[Music]
japanese chinese style child
[Music]
you're so close
is it good
nice and now we watch one piece while
eating because
we're that kind of family
i think oh
struggles vlogging struggles yeah
turmoil
a real human
[Applause]
this is the highest concentration of
tech youtube lifestyle crew that has
ever gathered 13 videos this weekend
all right okay we're off to lunch oh yes
so where's the seat belt
not in the middle on the sides i
understand
[Music]
friends
[Music]
uh
[Music]
bet
liberty station
content creators doing content creator
things
we're gonna film some tick tocks because
these two are teaching me how to take
talk because i don't know how to tic
talk and grandma over here needs to
learn
[Music]
oh all right let's say bye to jeremiah
bye
all right how do you feel
one of the this is is this the first
group creator meetup that you hosted
i think so
i want to say yeah in person yeah yeah i
mean especially
oh no
like especially within our youtuber like
circle i think so it's fun we got to
talk about a lot of stuff that i always
itch to talk about
and it feels nice to talk to people who
just get it you know
well thank you for bringing us together
online in person
i'm so glad
hello happy
sunday today's super bowl sunday
and i'm making lunch right now and i'm
making
the famous ichiran tonkotsu ramen so our
friends got this for us for christmas
and it's gonna expire this week so i
thought i would uh
make it i figured i should make like
tokubatsuna special like toppings and
not just put green onions on top so i'm
gonna attempt making some very quick
chashu with some pork belly that i have
and i'm boiling some eggs right now my
mouth is watering right now i'm really
excited to eat it let's cook okay so i
made some
uh pork belly
okay okay
it's looking pretty good it's looking
pretty good so while i was cooking the
cha shoo
i decided watching tv because i was like
i have seven minutes of this thing to
left to brace
and i turn on the tv to tv japan which
is like this like one channel
um that we get through a tv provider
where it streams a bunch of like
random japanese tv shows and movies and
stuff
and usually it's very light-hearted
especially in the afternoon at like one
o'clock there's like kids shows on so
like great i just want to watch like
light-hearted japanese tv there was this
movie on and it looked really serious
and i was like yeah sure i'll watch a
bit of this movie and it turned really
dark really fast without getting into
too much detail
basically one character did something
absolutely terrible to another character
which is one of my
biggest fears
as a woman just out in the world y'all
ladies probably
can guess
and
god it was so heavy
i like couldn't i like turn it off
because i was like nope i cannot do this
nope and then turn back on again because
i was like i wanna make sure she's fine
and then i turned and then i was like
nope she's not i'm gonna turn it off
again and then i turn it back on again
and then it was like the next scene but
i was like oh my god so i like pulled up
the movie on my phone
and i read the rest of the synopsis of
the movie because i'm definitely not
gonna watch the rest of it
and uh turns out she's gonna be fine
but i was like oh my god it's just like
imagery like that i would love to have a
heads up you know like i love that
certain things on social media these
days have that content warning of like
you can opt into this
um instead of opting out but like
traditional tv i guess doesn't
and i just really didn't need to see
that today
stuff like that is really bad for me i
just i don't do well with that kind of
stuff i don't like watching
movies that
have like needless
violence or maybe it's an important part
of the plot in which
in
which case i just don't want to watch it
because
like it's just it feels like i'm
my biggest fears are being actualized
and
it doesn't help to have an image of that
in my brain and now it's there
now it's there i can't do anything about
i can't unwatch it
so i just went
to go tell scott what happened and i
told him that
i i'm not gonna go anywhere without him
anymore
it does make me scared to just be a
woman honestly
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right it's done
yo that looks freaking good
look at that
that looks amazing
[Music]
you